okay part baths OMG from Brazil again so
let's exchange only five again sir this
Philidor approach so i already had this
a couple of times and basically play it
without knowing any theoretical details
or maybe it's a it's possible in this
kind of position yeah that's a decent
idea it tries to exchange it's bad
bishop not much I can do about this
well I can try to do the same okay maybe
just Kenya 7 first okay yeah maybe he
tries to get it's an eye to d3 you're
just a good square to put some pressure
on e5 so yeah Alex exchange first now
night c5 to keep an eye on the square if
we could place before I can just go to
e6 I think surprising okay but this
night didn't have any you'd shown
prospects on c3 anyway so it's not a not
a move without its points yeah do have
anything better than just exchanging
don't think so
okay maybe now a five and i know i
activate my rook so this way
maybe not sure look everyone perhaps I'm
a little bit more active in this
position okay it's nothing white should
be too worried about that it's a little
bit to do something how to improve the
position interesting right can we can
play a forward some point maybe maybe
this is an idea to get him to play c3
and then go to to the second rank yeah
okay okay this is equal it's not
possible to do to do much here
is there some way to to get some
activity going here I could I could play
h5 with the idea of g5 this could also
be bad for me I must admit yeah but it's
it's interesting to try out maybe it's
too ambitious idea would be to transfer
the night from e62 g6 to get him to take
on g5i is traveling over to the Queen
side ok 1g six so if he takes I would
have chances to together on the pawn
going here ok what is this kind of just
take on g4
check
hmm justing shouldn't well what what
what Wow a little bit irritated
so possible to keep an extra porn
somehow I take with an i-team might just
go to g1 to pick pick up ef3 it so
that's no extra porn time warning I
don't think I have anything better bra
offered ok declined the draw draw oh no
he's offering himself gain draw ya know
used to try anything with 50 seconds of
course it's it's a complete draw anyway
but G for business really really
irritated me just just just make it
quick check with the computer should be
good for me what can I do there some of
the engine is not working so i have to
work it out for myself
yeah but it's it looks looks looks
forced amazing you played this is just a
couple of seconds time spend okay guy
can take edge for of course but no idea
okay let's go for another game